in 2013 the world celebrated Rashad
varnas 200th birthday and to end the
year we embarked on a caribbean
adventure
human artists cachos installation is our
route to the teatro nacional
it's part of the stage set for the
first-ever vogner opera to be presented
in Cuba the flying dutchman in this
modern interpretation the protagonist
has been turned into a restless soul in
contemporary Havana the Opera is being
performed in German for director andreas
Besler working here has been a
completely new experience thus often big
sign is friendly thus the journey itself
is the essential component here it's not
the destination that's interesting but
the journey creating an atmosphere of
departure the cars of sailors give it
unexpected energy in keeping with Agnes
holistic approach to his compositions
vasila works with the Cuban singers to
lend physical expression to both music
and rhythm one of their biggest
difficulties is pronouncing the lyrics
correctly
singing out loud oh so pro would provide
it's wonderful to be able to learn this
music but for us it's a lot of work
getting the text right and it's a
challenge getting the articulation to
convey Wagner's awesome sound Batman in
C Ward riffs to Z deepest Indian tote
dine bleep joy eigen none of the singers
have ever performed in German before
Parliament inquire like to start working
with the chorus members is incredibly
dynamic they learn very quickly as for
the soloists we'll have to see how the
neurons slowly link up to produce
something that sounds really good Oh
what's a doll's compass was a good clean
soprano Johanna Simone is playing Santa
and she's considered quite a discovery
born in Havana in 1980 she belongs to a
generation of well-trained young singers
who want to extend their repertoire
until now mainly Italian operas have
been performed in Cuba after singing in
Mexico Peru and Spain Johanna now hopes
bogna will secure her a place in the
international music business if Pharaoh
holla my hope which is probably the
dream for almost all singers is to sing
and by hoyt it would be like singing at
the met or La Scala in Milan because it
is a truly emblematic venue in my
profession you are emblematic going and
Mimi do and with 60 Vagner ides from
across Europe coming in especially for
the occasion she may have a chance
they're found in Cuba's first local
bogna society aimed at promoting talent
and doing a spot of advertising for the
composer on the island
this in second we are very glad to have
achieved our aim we have set a Cuban
milestone and now we plan to continue
this afternoon we expect a wonderful
performance with the Cuban singers in
top form and there's no doubt that
they're cut out for vogner both in terms
of their acting and their musical
capabilities
the only guest artist is Ukrainian
baritone andrei merzlikin who plays the
Dutchman he fitted into the ensemble
seamlessly
he in the Cuban center matched each
other beautifully you cannot come from
Munich and goodness knows were spoiled
but it was a worthy start of a German
Cuban musical community and passion for
bogner leidenschaft no sad revilla
combined net until now we never dared to
sing vogner here because it's something
special it requires very special voices
yeah many so I'm glad we can perform him
here now jelly idiot but I look like I'm
so impressed by Senta such a warm
lyrical voice is hard to find especially
in magna but I also really like the
steersman with his light tenor it was
really good ensemble work never hopped
is fine horn globule the ensemble eyes
song bogna in Havana this Caribbean
version of The Flying Dutchman would be
a credit to many a German stage
and for some of the singers it's
definitely a calling card for European
opera houses and maybe even a ticket to
buy Hoyt
if that's whetted your appetite for
vogner just go to DW de / english /
partner 200 you'll find lots of
information on the great German composer
on our website